c'est incroyable ça dit beaucoup de la
société mais il faut pas lui donner le
poids que ça n'a pas quand même parce
que c'est malgré tout très marginal ces
situations là mais ça traduit quelque
chose qui est le développement du vol
qui est aujourd'hui plus important qu'il
ne l'était et parce que mécaniquement
quand vous êtes confronté à l'envie de
mais que vous n'avez pas la capacité de
il y a une partie d'entre nous sans nous
général évidemment qui ne séparésister
et ben pour les enseignes quand vous
faites voler une bouteille d'alcool ou
un filet de bœuf parce que finalement
c'est la même somme ben ça fait un trou
dans la caisse et donc les enseignes
réagissent alors elle réagissent comme
vous l'avez montré mais encore une fois
je vous le redis c'est des cas
exceptionnels la règle aujourd'hui qu'il
est la plus fréquente c'est elles sont
toutes en train d'investir dans des
heures de sécurité ça veut dire
aujourd'hui il y a un boulevard pour les
vigiles franchement je sais quelque
chose parce que si c'est intéressant
parce que pardon parce que j'ai compris
comment ça marche
je n'étais pas de moi j'ai discuté avec
un sociologue ce qui est intéressant
c'est pas tant ça en Angleterre
maintenant ils mettent aussi sur le sur
le beurre il met des antivols ce que
sociologue me disait c'est qu'avant les
gens beaucoup pour du divertissement du
luxe des jeux bien sûr aujourd'hui les
gens veulent pour manger
et quand les gens ont faim la dernière
fois que les gens ont eu faim c'était
1789 quand les gens ont faim la fin
c'est les pires des choses il descendent
dans la rue on est dans une situation je
crois que personne n'imagine les gens
même rendent dans le magasin ils mangent
dans le magasin ils viennent pas voler
quelque chose moi j'appelle ça lundi
serai au lit vous savez qu'il y a lundi
sincère on en entend parler tous les
jours c'est aujourd'hui on est à peu
près à 6% d'évolution de l'inflation
quand on la regarde macro générale ce
que j'appelle l'indice ravioli parce que
c'est la réalité c'est le prix des
boîtes de raviolis bien sûr maintenant
la boîte de raviolis je prends l'exemple
le plus extrême ça a pris selon les
marques tenez-vous bien entre 50 et 80%
vous entendez oui oui bien sûr c'est ce
que j'appelle l'indice ravioli et les
gens pour lequel manger difficile bah
ils achètent plus souvent des raviolis
qui n'achètent tous les produits qui
composent le panier de l'INSEE et donc
en fait aujourd'hui il y a une espèce de
hiatus dans la société entre ce que des
gens qui sont à la difficulté entendre
en disant mais ça fait plus 6 succède
bon c'est pas violent et ce qu'il voit
dans les rayons parce que quand vous
voyez que votre boîte de raviolis est
passé de 2 à 3 euros ok peut-être que
pour nous c'est pas beaucoup mais pour
celui qui a pas une thune c'est énorme
et donc après ça peut produire ce genre
de comportement et c'est ça que vous
montrez alors on parlait d'un Marceau
rouge je parlais même la masse et je
l'assume totalement grogner on y est
dans le marché rouge le rythme
d'inflation par exemple en mars la
semaine dernière l'inflation sur les
grandes marques alimentaires en grande
distribution sur la semaine vous
entendez bien ça fait plus
1,1%. si vous le mettez en rythme manuel
c'est juste une construction
mathématique ça fait plus 50 alors
évidemment ça va pas faire ça et depuis
quatre semaines le rythme ne cesse de sa
croix donc on a une accélération et
c'est ça le sentiment de mur dans lequel
on est c'est-à-dire qu'on a des clients
qui vivent en quelques semaines le même
niveau d'inflation que ce qu'ils ont
vécu l'année dernière en quelques mois
et donc quand vous êtes dans la merde et
ben forcément vous prenez le mur de face
juste sur France 5 hier je vous ai
regardé j'ai zappé pendant une pub sur
France pendant une pub sur France 5 et
j'adorais Alain Duhamel à juste une
phrase où est Macron oh depuis le second
mandat pardon et Macron les retraites
les machins les les gens dans la rue les
gens qui regardent faim j'ai rien contre
lui mais où est-il c'est pour ça par
exemple que moi j'étais favorable au
panier anti-inflation voulu par Olivia
Grégoire l'entend pas de commerce mais
parce qu'ils ont fait depuis ce qui
s'appelle le trimestre anti-inflation
parce que les enseignes n'ont pas voulu
en faire un chacune des enseignants nous
on veut pas en faire qu'une mais on veut
bien faire chacun un autre ok très bien
ils ont en paqueté ça en appelant
trimestre anti inflation on peut
considérer que c'est la communication
gouvernementale et ce qu'effectivement
pour une part c'est de la com
l'inflation ne s'arrêtera pas la porte
des magasins mais néanmoins vis-à-vis de
ceux qui sont dans la difficulté ça
envoie quand même le signal qui il se
passe des choses ils font des choses
peut-être pas assez mais au moins un peu
et ça peut apaiser le climat social
parce qu'effectivement là on est
d'accord on a on est sur un brasier
de clémentine
non mais j'imagine que tout ça un coup
en terme de main d'oeuvre de sécurité
est-ce que ça va encore augmenter les
prix des produits le fait de poser des
antivols sur chaque produit même de
première nécessité d'un Street point de
vue théorique oui parce que chaque geste
a un coût d'un point de vue pratique
c'est marginal quand vous le ramenez au
nombre d'articles concernés donc oui
mais non ça fait pas une réponse voilà
très très tranchée mais non ça n'aura
pas d'effet visible l'inflation de
l'énergie des matières premières à plus
d'effet manifestement mon inflation
ravioly c'est plus violent que le coût
de l'antivol oui
vous expliquer que c'est marginal mais
néanmoins quand on regarde le profil des
voleurs il y a des jeunes il y a des
maires de famille il y a des personnes
âgées ça veut dire toute la société
c'est ça qui est parce que toute la
société est confronté à l'inflation et
vous savez la pauvreté ou la difficulté
elle ne cible pas telle ou telle là on
va faire de la sociologie de base étage
peut-être mais c'est quand même ça
malheureusement ça concerne beaucoup de
gens voilà quel que soit leur origine
leur âge voilà et donc
et là où c'est pire dans ce que l'on vit
c'est que la partie de la population qui
consacre le plus de son budget à la
nourriture c'est précisément celle le
moindre ressources donc ça veut dire que
quand ils entendent à la radio à la télé
que l'inflation a fait plus 6 alors que
eux parce qu'ils ont ils gagnent pas
beaucoup qui consacrent peut-être 40% de
leurs dépenses à l'alimentation qui
elle-même fait 15 ou 20 bah en
proportion ça devient insupportable
parce que c'est les plus fragiles qui
sont les plus confrontés par l'inflation
alimentaire par principe c'est vrai mais
les veulent aussi se répandent parce
qu'il y a aussi un problème avec la
justice la justice aujourd'hui n'a pas
les moyens de poursuivre les choses et
c'est un peu une forme d'impunité mais
pour ces Larsen là comme malheureusement
pour des tas d'autres je vais pas faire
Montréal là-dessus mais bon c'est pas le
seul sujet sur lequel on peut considérer
que la justice est un manque de moyens
alors oui non mais la société la
publicité a très bien compris et les les
enseignes des supermarchés ont compris
d'ailleurs dans quelle situation on
était parce que la publicité reflète la
vraie vie et là il y a des publicités
pour les enseignes que vous avez
peut-être vues où on voit que 1 euro
c'est une somme colossale pour les gens
il y a une publia une enseigne qui parle
de 1 euro avec un euro vous êtes
des tempêtes sur le court d'énergie donc
en fait envisager prédire avec certitude
qu'en juin ça va baisser c'est présente
que c'est pour ça qu'on peut juste dire
il y a une probabilité pour que d'ici
juin ça va monter là ça monte fort puis
après ça va se calmer un peu mais malgré
tout on continue à monter et d'ici au
mois de juin il est quand même très
improbable qu'on soit moins de 10-12 %
d'inflation par rapport au premier
janvier sur le panier il parle de 20%
les économistes sur le panier de la
manager de 20% de ça s'appelle une
inflation galopante et j'aime beaucoup
Bruno Le Maire mais la dernière fois il
a dit qu'il allait manager tout ça il a
pas mal agi du tout rassurer il peut
rien faire et là les économistes quand
tu leur parles parle d'inflation
galopante ça veut dire qu'on peut aller
jusqu'à des 20% sur les et et vraiment
moi je suis très inquiet tout le monde
tout le monde est très très inquiet
merci en tout cas d'avoir été avec nous